Today, we’re learning English with the
Disney classic animation “The Little Mermaid”.
We’ve selected two scenes from this iconic Disney film to
teach you some great vocabulary and pronunciation features.
Many of our viewers have seen a dramatic improvement in
their English skills with our videos - viewers like Swarachita,
who has learned a lot of native vocabulary,
pronunciation and cultural aspects from our channel.
If you want to learn English in a fun and dynamic way
and be able to watch your favorite movies and TV series
without getting lost, without missing
the jokes and without subtitles,
make sure you hit that subscribe button and bell
down below so that you don’t miss any of our new lessons.
By the way, do you ever feel lost when us
natives speak fast? It’s frustrating, isn’t it?
We cut some words. We connect others.  It does not
sound anything like what you learned in school.
That’s why in our Fluent with Friends
course we take you outside of the classroom
and help you learn English as it is really spoken,
and have a ton of fun doing it with Friends,
which various academic studies show is
the best TV series out there for learning English.
Can you imagine being able to understand English as
effortlessly as you understand your native language?
Well you CAN, and guess what?  You can try it
absolutely free with our 3-part masterclass!
So learn more and sign up by clicking up
here or down in the description below now.
If you love learning with Disney movies then I
highly recommend you check out our Disney Playlist
so that you can choose your next lesson!